have to buy a hundred hours of its time
at $250 an hour so what does that mean
I want to get your opinion on this just
give me a dumb or awesome
the websites called human IPO app these
guys are doing a very fancy branding
around an old idea so what it does is I
can go I can go do a human IPO so I'm
Shawn I go public I get a stock ticker
which is like you know sha or whatever
and I basically IPO off a share of my
time so I can action off up to 500 hours
of my time that you can book from me at
a certain price and then if people think
hey you know this Shawn guy he's on you
know he's on the way up his time is
gonna be more valuable in the future I'm
gonna buy a unit of this guy's time I
can either hold it and trade it later at
a higher price or I can I can I guess
use it to like book an hour of my time
so this is the core idea on the website
now it's incredibly interesting tell me
what you think of it for sure
interesting for sure innovative in while
and whoever invented this is a nerd and
I love those types of people
logistically I just don't think it makes
sense because well so I can buy Brian's
time well so if it was I'm looking at
this right now I don't understand why
they call it like it's they're really
just rebranding just like expert
networks and consulting like it's just
like dude something screwed so I think
clarity fm it's the same thing
[Music]
definitely cool highly unlikely to work
right that's what I think I think this
is like an art project that's me this is
I don't know your how did you find this
I saw it on my think product hunt and I
was like yeah I've been following I
think I talked about to some of the
previous things I've been following
these personal I SEOs personal personal
coins that people are creating in the
cryptic note
this is not crypto but it's the same
idea and I think it sort of has the same
pros and cons I think it's like kind of
exciting in a way to like bet on people
and I think it's kind of lame in the way
which is like what do I get I get an
hour of their time like no on this you
have like this guy I just clicked on you
have to buy a hundred hours of its time
at $250 an hour so what does that mean
turn is that wait is a 25 grand or turn
50 grand
I didn't hear exactly you said but you
have to buy a hundred hours from him at
Tutor and $50 so that's 25 or 25 grand
yeah
so I but like I don't think like if I
was this guy and I just sold a hundred
hours of my time I have a feeling that I
would bail on a lot of that yeah so one
one piece is are you actually gonna
fulfill the second is so what am i doing
it's actually basically like a
freelancer selling blocks of design time
or programming time or consulting hours
or whatever it is okay that's cool maybe
first really special unique people that
works I don't think this is that
interesting overall the ones I think are
more interesting are the ones where you
actually get a piece of their earnings
over the next X years let's never do
that a million years I know but some
people would some people would say cool
I'll take you know it's like people who
raise money for their company right
they're selling off future earnings for
capital today and some people might want
instead of doing it for your company you
might do it for yourself so I think it's
interesting I want to see somebody like
I'm gonna sign up for use case I'm gonna
I wanna but do you know these guys can
you introduce me can I be what are these
people that they that can I sell hundred
hours it seems it does seem interesting
I'm just just from like a like an like
an innovation perspective like it's just
so weird interesting I would love to I
would love to try this
you
[Music]
[Applause]